[Musique]
bonjour nous recevons dans notre salle
aux cadis spécial municipal aujourd'hui
olivier bérisson candidat donc aux
élections municipales et communautaires
pour la commune de saint-esprit
vous êtes aussi olivier bérisson le
président du mouvement politique et
spirituelle moon
alors justement j'ai retrouvé une de vos
citations qui dit je suis dans la
décolonisation spirituel alimentaire
médicale intellectuels politiques
sociales sociétales musicale cultuelle
culturels historiques et même sexuelle
du bourreau
quel lien direct établissez vous entre
votre credo que je viens de lire la et
votre candidature aux élections
municipales
vous avez tout dit je peux partir c'est
à dire qu'en réalité nous venons
réinstaller ce qu'on appelle la filiale
it et donc ça veut dire que tout ce qui
a été fait pour marchandises est
commercialisé rendre faire concurrentiel
tous les éléments de la vie nous venons
nous 10e au contraire qu'il y a tout
pour que tout soit en unités de la vie
donc vous allez mettre cette dimension
spirituelle de votre mouvement politique
en avant dans cette campagne des
municipales cet aspect il faut bien que
la commune soit le porte flambeau de son
appellation
donc nous nous considérons que l'huile
essentielle qui permet un être humain de
vivre en harmonie d'avoir toutes ses
capacités intellectuelles cognitive
physique d'appel d'offres m d'intel est
mise en avant
le saint-esprit justement regorge de ses
capacités en nous avec un foncier
important et donc nous avons un projet
assez fort justement là-dessus parce que
il suffit aussi ne suffit pas de
s'appeler saint-esprit il faut être sain
d'esprit
c'est le corps sain dames c'est
intellectuellement singes et aux rythmes
en simple sicot logiquement saint-esprit
esprit sain alors présenté nous
justement votre groupe d'action à
l'échelle municipale comment vous avez
constitué votre liste quel est votre
projet phare en dehors de ce que vous
nous avez déjà dit à la liste est
composée de personnes voulant être des
hommes politiques de terrain
alors quand je dis d'intégrer si
passionnément pas aux coups dans les
quartiers des hommes et des femmes
politiques des hommes et des femmes
politiques
c'est pas seulement parcouru les
quartiers c'est être au service et
proche des gens
mais c'est surtout être sociaux les
fronts nous voulons absolument changer
la donne politique
nous ne voulons plus être des hommes un
personnel politique qui se contentent de
s'asseoir de remplir des dossiers et
d'envoyer des courriers à bon donc vous
voulez faire de saint-esprit une sorte
de laboratoire ne sais pas s'il a été
allégé il a été par le passé on n'y a
participé à un certain nombre de
mouvements et il faut que nous puissions
insuffler sur l'ensemble de la
martinique et voir dans le monde entier
cette idée que nous devons nous prendre
nos mains nous responsabilité de
responsabiliser les élus ne peuvent plus
être cachée derrière les mouvements et
puis faire des petits courrier ou des
petits communiqué de presse donc que
c'est eux qui doivent être en avant ces
îles sont un rôle ce n'est pas aux
enfants d'aller au combat ce sont les
parents qui doivent aller aux offres
donc quand vous êtes élu vous devez être
qu'un élu sur lequel la population peut
compter pour aller sur les fronts
comment estimez vous la première
mandature du maire sortant fred michel
tir où je dirais que il n'y a pas eu de
montgolfier et je me théry là dessus
c'est votre seul commentaire de vérifier
si vous êtes élu quelle sera votre
dossier prioritaire en arrivant à la
tête de la municipalité spiritaines
d'écouter la priorité sera roi donné
l'assurance aux spiritains d'être écouté
d'être entendu d'être reçus comme des
personnes et des êtres humains à part
entière tout moun semoun donc nous
n'allons pas nous cacher derrière des
textes législatifs des côtes civile des
code pénal
non nous allons assumer l'entière
responsabilité qui nous sera donnée
c'est à dire de recevoir de construire
avec les spirit elle au projet et
surtout d'arrêter de faire de la
division entre jeunes moins jeunes et
plus âgés mais de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient des courroies de transmission et
qui fasse que
chaque être chaque spirit et se sentent
comme en moins sacré quelle est votre
première policière puisque à la parité
c'est ce qu'a dévoilé dans les prochains
jours je laisse la surprise
il y aura dix y aura des surprises merci
olivier bérisson d'avoir participé à ce
ca au caddie spécial municipal merci
beaucoup
[Musique]